hi guys um this is Mike well Mike is
myranda's dead this family that I'm a
part of a lot of people don't know the
context of the family I when my dad died
2008 my stepmom remarried this guy named
Edie Edie was all I knew
little did I know Edie was the patriarch
to an enormous family huge and you know
given that my my stepmom was my stepmom
I I didn't even I didn't even think very
much of this family cuz it's like my
stepmom remarries what does that mean to
me and what I didn't realize at the time
was that this family was full of really
great people who cared very deeply about
what I do and Mike here is some like
someone who has been supporting what I
do since before I was even doing it um
same with Miranda and Miranda when I
first started to YouTube was one of my
earliest supporters um not a fan you
know just honestly truly was proud of
what I was doing and she would often
like go to school and brag about the
fact that she was related to me and no
one believed her so she would every
Christmas we did new selfies and all
videos that we take Alan I want you to
explain the context because it is
important how you know people and and
how you meet people and how you involve
people in your life and and like the
kind of family that you hold in your
heart is sometimes even more important
than the family you have my blood and
you know
just wanted to give Mike here he he
wanted to just he wanted to say
something to you guys so take it away
oh thank all of Marc's fans from the
bottom of my heart I've read a lot of
the comments thank you so much for all
the prayers you know that the prayers
are probably would have helped me and my
wife in the rest of my family get
through these last couple days I
appreciate appreciate your guys's
understanding and him having to stop
what he's doing put his life on hold to
be with our family and help support us I
I also read a lot of the comments where
a lot of you have recently lost people
one and I want to pray for you guys
and I've also seen some of the ones
where the people are upset about the
thumbs down I don't know what you don't
know nurse I mean the context could be
not that they just like the video itself
but they could be just disliking the
whole situation so let's stop hating all
the people with thumbs down they they
who would actually would like a video
like that we're breaking news about on
East Nine but once again thank you so
much for all your prayers and all your
support
god bless all you and I just want to say
thank you as well because like I've
always avoided as channel there's never
been a business for me there's never
been just a normal adventure this this
channel they basically catalogs my
entire life and the the reality that I
often face you know life isn't always
the happy place that YouTube can make it
seem there's a lot of channels out there
that project only the you know the
positive sides of their life because
that's what they want people to see I've
I've I've never been of that mindset i I
I started this channel because I didn't
like who I was and I wanted to be better
and I wanted to have this be an
extension of who I was and and to
showcase that to everybody and and I
just want to say that
the feeling that I get when I know that
you guys are willing to support me
through thick and thin it's like it's an
indescribable feeling and in this one
scenario it extended beyond myself and
it extended to a family that I truly
honestly care about and I just want to
say thank you for that and I know Mike
didn't necessarily want me to but I set
up a GoFundMe to help with funeral
expenses the goals not incredible it's
$15,000 it's just a cover literally just
the funeral expenses and don't feel in
any way obligated to donate and I'm like
who was gonna kill me if I had gone out
there and then pushed really hard for it
so if you have any spare money like just
a dollar feel free but no pressure if
you don't have money don't donate if you
have money and don't want to donate
that's fine too
don't no pressure in any way shape or
form the link is in the description you
can also just go there write a lovely
note I saw on the memorial page for
Miranda that there were so many people
that live candles and send flowers in
and just thank you guys for that
really honestly truly just thank you
thank you and with that I will be back
in a couple more days I think I head
home tomorrow and her head home to LA
tomorrow and then just another data
skits settled back in and then I should
be back in this one I think so thanks
guys thank you see you soon bye